and for those of us not familiar with
this conference the annual conference
that Putin actually carries out just
give us a little bit of color because
this is a big big event it's an annual
event and it has stretched up to four
hours and 14 minutes that was a record
set in 2008
last year it was three hours and ten
minutes
you know this year where we're still in
the three hours 45 and still going it's
essentially you know one of the several
major platforms for him he has another
one where he has a sort of televised
link-up with the with the nation which
is very much on domestic policy here
this is an opportunity for him as well
to talk quite a lot about foreign policy
but of course the economy is an
important part I mean it's 18 months to
go before elections in which he's widely
expected to run for a fourth and final
term he was asked about that today and
as usual he gave the same answer which
is he evaded it and said that he would
decide when the time comes and we've got
to say I haven't seen the movie style
trailer for this particular annual news
conference but I've seen the ones that
have gone before and they're pretty
spectacular in terms of the meat on the
bones that we're getting from this
conference at the moment the alleged
interference in the electoral process in
this country in the United States what
were his comments on that he said you
know that there's no proof who did it
which is you know the position that he's
maintained throughout but went on to say
that what was important was the
information that was leaked to public
opinion and then he also accused Hillary
Clinton of being a bad loser and said
that Russia was the only country that
had actually predicted that Trump would
win